Monday morning at Munich Airport and not
a passenger in sight here as in other
major German airports all flights are
canceled because two unions representing
millions of public sector Workers are
striking overpay and conditions and some
people are stranded well if I had known
it I wouldn't have come around and tried
I'm a bit shocked actually
so was it I never I didn't heard of it
so yeah
I have to find out what to do right now
the action by the Verdi and aegie fowl
unions has hit the entire German
transport Network in large swathes of
the country fleets of buses have been
stuck in their Depots the rail network
has also been paralyzed with all
long-distance Journeys canceled and many
Regional links also abandoned for the
day on most Mondays in March this
station would be a hive of activity with
trains going to dozens of different
destinations both regionally across the
country and internationally but this
Monday virtually no trains are running
and where normally more than 300 000
people would come and go through this
station on this Monday barely a fraction
of that number are actually here the
unions are clear they want above
inflation pay Rises and better working
conditions
our goal for the strike is not to impact
passengers and school children but to
affect management Boards of all the
companies they are responsible because
they are the ones paying their staff low
wages the companies have rejected that
view and the pay demand behind it
millions of passengers who depend on
buses and trains are suffering because
of this excessive and overblown strike
not everyone can work from their home
office thousands of companies in the
economy that usually receive or ship
their goods by rail are also suffering
the German Central Bank has appealed for
a reason calling on unions to make
sensible pay rise demands and for
companies to accept sensible profit
margins
one Minister involved in negotiations
with the unions says an offer on the
table is fair but so far the unions
don't agree and won't rule out more
strike action Dominic Kane Al Jazeera
Berlin